we'll now learn about what is arguably
the most useful concept in finance and
that's called the present value and if
you know the present value then it's
very easy to understand the net present
value and the discounted cash flow and
the internal rate of return and we'll
eventually learn all of those things but
the present value what does that mean
present value so let's let's do a a
little exercise I could pay you a
hundred dollars today so let's say today
today I could pay you 100 dollars or
it's up to you or in one year in one
year I will pay you I don't know let's
say in a year I agree to pay you a
hundred and ten dollars and my question
to you and this is a fundamental
question of Finance everything will
build upon this is which one would you
prefer and this is guaranteed I
guarantee you I'm either gonna pay you a
hundred dollars today and there's no
risk even if I get hit by a truck or
whatever this is going to happen the US
government if the earth exists we will
pay you 110 dollars in one year it is
guaranteed so there's no risk here so
it's just a notion of you're definitely
going to get a hundred dollars today in
your hand or you're definitely going to
get $100
110 dollars one year from now so how do
you compare the two and this is where
present value comes in what if there
were a way to say well what is $110 a
guaranteed $110 in the future what if
there were a way to say how much is that
worth today how much is that worth in
today's terms so let's let let's do a
little thought experiment let's say that
you could put money in some let's say
you could put money in the bank and you
know these days banks are kind of risky
but let's say you could put it in the
safest bank in the world let's say you
although someone would debate you put it
in government Treasuries which are
considered risk safe because a risk free
because the US government the Treasury
can always indirectly print more money
well will one day do a whole thing on
the money supply but at the end of the
day the US government has the rights on
on the printing press etc it's more
complicated than that but for those
purposes we assume that a US Treasury
which essentially is you're lending
money to the US government that it's
risk-free so let's say that you you
could lend money let's say today I could
give you $100 and that you could invest
it at 5% risk-free so you could invest
it five percent risk-free and then in a
year from now how much would that be
worth in a year that would be worth 100
five dollars in one year actually let me
write the 110 dollars over here right so
this was a good way of thinking about it
you're like okay instead of taking the
money from Sal a year from now I'm
getting $110 if I were to take the
hundred dollars today and put it in
something risk-free in a year I would
have a hundred and five dollars so
assuming I don't have to spend the money
today this is a better situation to be
in right if I take the money today and
risk-free invested it five percent I'm
going to end up with 105 dollars a year
instead if you just tell me Sal just
give me the money in a year give me $110
you're going to end up with more money
in a year right you're going to end up
with $110 and that is actually the right
way to think about it and remember
everything and I keep saying it over and
over again everything I'm talking about
it's it's critical that we're talking
about risk-free once you introduce risk
and we have to start introducing
different interest rates and
probabilities and we'll get to that
eventually but I want to just give the
purest example right now so already
you've made the decision but we still
don't know what present value was so to
some degree when you took this hundred
dollars and you said well if I lend it
to the government or five lend it to a
risk-free bank at five percent in the
year they'll give me $105 this $105 is a
way of say
what is the one-year value of $100 today
right what is a one-year out value of
$100 today so what if we want it to go
in the other direction if we have a
certain amount of money and we want to
figure out today's value what could we
do well to go from here to here what did
we do we essentially took $100 we took
$100 and we multiplied by one we
multiplied by one plus five percent so
that's 1.05 so to go the other way to
say how much money if I were to grow it
by five percent would end up being $110
we'll just divided by 1.05 and then we
will get the present value and the
notation is PV we'll get the present
value of one hundred and ten dollars a
year from now so one hundred ten year
from now year from now so the present
value the present value of $110 in let's
say in 2009 it's currently 2008 I don't
know what year you're watching this
video in hopefully people will be
watching this in the next millennia but
the present value of $110 in 2009
assuming right now is 2008 a year from
now is equal to $110 $110 divided by
1.05 which is equal to and let's take
out this calculator which is probably
overkill for this problem let me clear
everything okay so I want to do 110
divided by 1.05 is equal to 100 for
pointless round 0.76 so it equals 100
four point seven six dollars so the
present value of $110 a year from now if
we assume that we could invest money
risk-free at 5% if we were get today the
present value of that is let me do it in
a different color just to fight the
monotony the present value is equal to
one hundred and four dollars and seventy
six cents another way to kind of just
talk about this is to get the present
value of $100 ten dollars a year from
now we discounted the value by a
discount rate and the discount rate is
this right here we grew the money by you
could say I don't are yielding our
interest here we're discounting the
money because we're going backwards in
time we're going from year out to the
present and so this is our yield to to
compound the amount of money we invest
we multiply the amount we invest times
one plus the yield then to discount
money in the future to the present we
divide it by one plus the discount rate
so this is a 5% discount rate 5%
discount rate to get its present value
so what does this tell us this tells us
if if someone's willing to pay $110
assuming this 5% from this is a critical
assumption this tells us that if I tell
you I'm willing to pay you $110 a year
from now and you could get 5% so you
could kind of say that 5% is your
discount rate risk-free that you should
be willing to take today's money if
today I'm willing to give you more than
the present value so if this comparison
were let me let me clear all of this or
let me just scroll down so let's say
that one year so today one year so we
figured out that $110 $110 a year from
now its present value its present value
is equal to so the present value of that
110 is equal to 104 dollars and 76 cents
so and that's because I used a 5%
discount and that's a key assumption but
what this tells you is this is a dollar
sign and it's hard to read what this
tells you is is that if if your choice
was between $110 a year from now and
$100 today $100 today you should take
$110 a year from now why is that because
it's present value is worth more than
100 however if I were to offer you a
hunt the $110 a year from now or a
hundred and five dollars today this the
$105 today would be the better choice
because its present value right $105
today you don't have to discount it it's
it's today it's present value is itself
$105 today is worth more than the
present value of 110 which is 104
dollars and 76 cents another way to
think about it is I can take this 105
dollars in the bank get let's see I
let's assume I have a risk for you rank
get 5% on it and then I would have what
would I end up with I would end up with
105 times 1.05 is equal to $110 and a
quarter so a year from now I'd be better
off by a quarter and I have the joy of
being able to touch my money for a year
which is hard to hard to quantify so we
leave it out of the equation anyway I'll
see you in the next video